Speaker 1: Let's go next to Jay
are from Atlanta. Welcome, J.W.
are.
Speaker 2: Welcome. Thanks for having me,
baby. How am I? How am I coming in as far as,
like, the sound is too rough or whatnot or.
Speaker 1: It's okay. I
think it's definitely doable.
Speaker 2: I don't know if you've covered this
on your show before, but what is your take on the
AMA? Okay. So in the polls, it appears it
appears that work that Raphael Warnock has
has not a sizable but a lead over Herschel Walker.
But then you. But then there. But then there seems
to be. But then you look over at the governor's
race and it at best appears appears to be very
close between Stacey Abrams and Brian Kemp.
I just wanted to hear your thoughts on the
AMA. Your thoughts on the possible
ticket splitting going on here and what
you think the explanation for that might be?
Speaker 1: That's a good question. I don't I
don't know enough about. So. Okay, the way these
polls are typically done is people are asked,
how likely are you to vote? And who do you plan
to vote for? How strong is your support for that
person? Are you a 100% in for this person or
are you leaning that way or whatever? And then
you kind of blend it and you get a final polling
number. Now, intuitively, if we're talking about
Georgia voters and you go to Georgia voters
and you pull them about the Kemp Abrams race
and you pulled them about the Warnock Walker
race, it's both are totally statewide races.
So everybody in the state is allowed to vote.
If you have a difference, it means one of two
things. Some people plan to vote in one of those
races and not the other. That would be one reason,
right? You plan to go and vote for the governor's
race and just leave blank the Senate or you plan
to vote for different parties? You might vote for
Brian Kemp, the Republican for the gubernatorial,
but then for Raphael Warnock, the Democrat in
the Senate race, which also seems kind of weird
and counterintuitive. So I actually don't know
why you you would imagine that you would have
almost identical numbers. Now, there's a there's
a counterpoint to that incumbency. Stacey Abrams
is the challenger. Raphael Warnock is the
incumbent. So to some degree, you might have
people who are only marginally paid, paying
attention, who are just leaning towards the
person who's currently in that office. And that
may be a reason why we see different numbers,
but it is sort of weird and counterintuitive.
Speaker 2: Right. Although, although it could
possibly speak volumes of it speaks
volumes about the fact that Herschel
that Herschel Walker's was. Well, I won't I
won't say a word candidate, but not maybe as
strong as some would have expected. Possibly.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, that's possible. I
it would be this would be a great question for a
polling expert. I feel like that we should have on
and actually ask specifically what explains this.
Speaker 2: Right. I only I just because like
I I'm a I'm a I'm a poll workers poll
and Fulton County and like I, I mean,
I can't I can't comment. I can't comment in
explicit detail on these things. But it is like
an interest. It is like an interesting phenomenon.
Speaker 1: Absolutely. Absolutely. I mean,
to look for an expert to talk to about
this, I think it is an interesting issue.
Speaker 2: All right. Thank you. All right.
Speaker 1: J.W. Ah. Thank you so much for the
call. Very much. Appreciate it. Let's go next to
Jen from Illinois. Jen, welcome to the show. Jen
from Illinois, welcome. You're on the air. And
Jen from Illinois, last opportunity. You are on
the air. And Jen is gone. That's truly a shame.
It's really a shame that that that that happened